we're told that given the height h and
volume v of a certain cylinder jill uses
the formula r is equal to the square
root of v over pi h to compute its
radius to be 20 meters
if a second cylinder has the same volume
of the first but is 100 times taller
what is its radius
pause this video and see if you can
figure this out on your own
all right now let's do this together so
first i always like to approach things
intuitively so let's say the first
cylinder looks something like this
like this
and then the second cylinder here it's a
hundred times taller i would have
trouble drawing something that's 100
times taller but if it has the same
volume it's going to have to be a lot
thinner
so if as you if you want to maintain the
volume
as you make
the cylinder taller and i'm not going
anywhere close to 100 times as tall here
you're going to have to decrease the
radius so we would expect a radius to be
a good bit less than 20 meters so that's
just the first intuition just to make
sure that we somehow don't get some
number that's larger than 20 meters but
how do we figure out what that could be
well now we can go back to the formula
and we know that jill calculated that 20
meters is the radius so 20 is equal to
the square root of v over pi h
and if this formula looks unfamiliar to
you just remember the volume
of a cylinder is the area of one of the
either the top or the bottom so pi r
squared times the height
and if you were to just solve this for r
you would exact you would have this
exact formula that jill uses so this
isn't coming this isn't some new formula
this is probably something that you have
seen already
so we know that 20 meters is equal to
this
and now we're talking about a situation
where we're a height that is 100 times
taller
so this other cylinder is going to have
a radius of square root of v is going to
be the same so let's just write that v
there pi doesn't change it's always
going to be pi and now instead of h we
have something that is a hundred times
taller so we could write that as 100 h
and then what's another way to write
this well what i'm going to do is try to
bring out the hundreds so i still get
the square root of v over pi h so i
could rewrite this as the square root of
1 over 100
times v over
pi h which i could write as the square
root of 1 over 100 and i'm just using
properties of radicals here times the
square root of v over pi
h
now we know what the square root of v
over pi h is we know that that is 20 and
our units are meters so this is 20 and
then what's the square root of 1 over
100
well this is the same thing as 1 over
the square root of 100 and of course now
it's going to be times 20
times 20. well the square root of 100 i
should say the principal root of 100 is
10.
so the radius of our new cylinder of the
second cylinder is going to be 1 10 of
20 which is equal to 2 meters and we're
done the second
cylinder is going to have a radius of 2
meters which meets our intuition if we
increase our height by a factor of 100
then our radius decreases by a factor of
10 the reason why is because you square
the radius right over here so if height
increases by a factor of 100 if radius
just decreases by a factor of 10 it'll
make this whole expression still have
the same volume